if all men are predators would you say
that women are gold diggers with no
loyalty and only want to Rob men of
resources while claiming the victimhood
when things go awry wow that's I mean
that's a bit much that's a bit much but
but
there's whole Tick Tock accounts on how
to get money I'm not saying that isn't
it
I thought I don't think I think if you
look at the statistics of that and in
compare but the thing is I think the
bottom line is great if we look great
and people dying
are two different things
second video just but we'll talk yeah go
on I'm just asking would that be a fair
generalization to make about women it is
though that is what it is that is the
way
in the way it is it's fair you know what
I mean the thing is okay okay it is
it's fair to say that women are gold
diggers with no loyalty and only want to
Rob men out of resource says while
claiming victim when things go awry I
don't think that's fair but I think that
is the Viewpoint anyway
no I don't believe I don't believe
it because you've never done it yourself
well I'm not personally a Goldie yeah
I've never been around you I don't I
don't know you've never seen anything on
Tick Tock of women trying but that's
technology
okay okay but wouldn't you this is
contradicting everything you said it's
not yeah yeah because you were using
Tick Tock as an example earlier and I
know men are predators and I know women
that are gold diggers but who gets hurt
the most well hang on how do you know
I'm asking you I'm asking you this is
not a comparison I'm trying to see if
you're going to use the same logic that
you used earlier okay and you said it's
not a fair comparison I I think that is
the view that you said that's the view
but it's not a fair comparison no but
it's interesting how when the tables are
turned you think it's a fair comparison
[Music]
the whole point is you have a double
standard for men and for women go ahead
I just want to know why you feel all men
are predators I I like I said I I think
it was more in this case if I'm down in
Alleyway to me or the every
I just think like why are you why would
you I would never go down an Alleyway
alone how would you get home if that's
the only choice I would just live
somewhere safer so it's my fault I mean
I think you shouldn't put yourself in
bad situations let's be honest let's be
honest this is coming I did not say it
was your fault but I'm just saying wow
you said I should move why would you put
yourself in a bad situation uh like like
men know this they know not to go down
an Alleyway alone at night but women
think we're entitled to safety I just no
I don't think it's we think we're
entitled to no you do because you said
so we once said online supposedly one
safety but you claim that you protected
earlier
okay okay earlier you you said shouldn't
men protect us yes so that therefore
therefore you feel like you're entitled
to safety when throughout all of human
history nobody was entitled to safety
one I think men as as what they want to
be known they want to to be known as
protectors
men want to be known as protectors to
their women yeah not women they don't
know so you you are single that's why
I've chosen not to get with a man yeah
so why are you entitled to protection
from men that don't know you right
coupled with the fact that you think all
men are predators but after how many
times do I have to repeat myself I said
to you all the depending I said to you
numerous times it is depending on the
situation but the thing is the fact that
you said it is already in there I think
because I was instantly going to walking
down there
do you see yourself getting into a
relationship any time no no yes yeah so
wow do you know we were sorry we were
talking about earlier on about the
question you asked about how women view
men or
um or how many humans are as gold
diggers and all that kind of stuff
um there's a video
blessing
um I want you to play that and I'm gonna
get your guys views on it yeah I
actually saw something on Tick Tock um
um man he went to go see his daughter I
think him and his partner split up and
they've been in like Arguments for like
months or whatever and he went to the
house and she attacked him and she he
called the police on her and they
arrested him yeah I mean because men are
automatically are the aggressors
as well like if you call about someone a
woman abusing you they'll they'll they
see me you're the one abusing so it's
like a it's in there like terms of like
that it's how they trained
um yeah I know Australia is also another
place where they're considering um
giving boys vasectomies I feel like what
these things yeah so they say they say
instead of birth control and condoms and
all this stuff that since men have you
know more sperm that boy should just
have beef have forced vasectomies in
school that's the dumbest thing and they
talk about my body my choice but they
never talk about uh men don't have the
right to choose when it comes to
Selective Service in the U.S so they're
they're forced to be drafted if we ever
went into a war situation over their
body well I would like to point out
um just for people who like the way I
look at things it's how I process what
she's saying is you notice like she
keeps on mentioning this Alleyway kind
of scenario you think it's kind of
interesting that in the media when
people kind of portray rape it's
normally in the alleyway great
great portray this kind of stuff it's
normally in the alleyway anyway
the majority of it it's programmed
doesn't it it's scary people watch these
same videos especially the feminists
they watch these same videos they get
these same narratives and then in real
life they act like they live in
Alleyways and that this is like a
scenario that actually happens but it is
yeah but the thing is your Mo you're
most likely to get graped not in an
alley rate by somebody that you know of
course yeah your partner right so what
so why the alleyway analogy is what is
what you're saying Alleyways at night
it's because she I think she lives where
she lives
no I'm saying you're you're 32. and yeah
so you can't pick somewhere that's not
down in Alleyway is there not a cost of
living crisis or do you honestly think
it's that easy to pick up and move you
could move into a cheaper area outside
of the city there is always Solutions
okay you're telling me the only houses
that you could live in are down dark
alleyways
in all of wherever you live whatever
town you live in the only places that
you could pick to live you have to go
down dark alleyways
what is this wow does that make any
sense it doesn't that's yeah what do you
mean so every time as a woman we buy a
house we've got to scope the area to
check with it anyway yeah if I live but
why don't men just stop talking okay if
I I no I live I I live there's no
there's no guy that lives here and one
of my requirements when looking at
apartments was I need a front desk
person because I I want security because
I don't want to be in a dangerous
situation
um sorry I put off saying it because I'd
imagine I'm in Council so I didn't ever
say where do you know you know what you
just said which is very interesting he
said why don't guys stop stalking yeah
right you know Society doesn't you know
yeah exactly you know because
people get told not to do things all the
time we get told not to steal we get
told not to murder we get told not to
group we get tons to a lot of things
people still do it as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible